ici c'est marseille une ville
cosmopolite qu'on connaît pour sa
basilique son port ses étals de poissons
mais aussi son hôtel du département
celui des bouches du rhône surnommé tout
bonnement le grand bleu c'est cette
collectivité qui reçoit l'assemblée des
départements cette année une assemblée
qui commence par la commission d
outre-mer présidée par le vice président
du département la réunion et le
président de l'assemblée des
départements
l'occasion de faire l'état des lieux des
difficultés et des succès que
connaissent les autres
chaque que tom a ses spécificités après
il ya un fil conducteur qui est
nous vivons avec les mêmes ces êtres
humains qu'ils soient anti qu'ils soient
communaux
soit habitante de saint pierre et
miquelon de la polynésie où la galerie
le rsa reste le socle de solidarité pour
tous aujourd'hui il est important qu à
l'adf il y est continue cette commission
où se réunit les outre-mer et même dans
l'évolution de certains statuts
les gens présents le sien ça veut dire
que les élus sont ont envie de parler
ils ont envie de s'exprimer pour dire
leur vie d'élu au quotidien et leur vie
surtout de leur population
le fus ce qui se passe actuelle projet
commun des collectivités d'outre-mer
projet humain et cela mène comme pour
demain matin visite du ministre et de
à créer une motion
qui dit état des lieux voilà comment
nous les caisses qui arrive
et voilà nos propositions donc ses
projets à partir des états des lieux
c'est importance nouvelle réunion sans
délais les témoignages forts des
témoignages parfois troublant de la
difficulté dans laquelle se trouvent
actuellement les collectivités
d'outre-mer dans le cadre justement de
ce changement de politique de ce
changement de vision
outre mer c'est on voit les gens avec
passion les gens volontaires inventif et
nous souhaitons justement à partir de
l'association des départements
montrez un outre-mer volontaires positif
constructif mais qui a aussi de porter
un projet collectif
un projet transmis à l'état et qui
permettra peut-être à l'avenir de
fortifier les collectivités d'autre
[Musique]